congratulations on this both of you guys
uh so funny so action-packed
um Arnold this is so interesting that
this is your first ever TV series it's
almost hard to believe
now that you've done you know this one
and you have that all that experience
doing films what are the pros and cons
to each
I I really cannot see of any kind of a
disadvantage of doing a TV Set uh series
I I think the only thing that's really
different is that you have to focus on
your character and all this for a much
longer period of time because remember
we're shooting here eight hours which is
Eight Episodes and the movie is usually
two hours and so it's a much longer
period of time and it's a lot of work
and you have to really stay very
disciplined to a certain time schedule
and audit but then none of this is a
real problem because it was fun it was
fun to do the action we had enough time
to really prep for the action and for
the stancing of this and I think that I
was you know as usual relying very
heavily on my cast and I had a fantastic
cast around me and that's what makes
them the movie when you have really good
Dynamics like I was extremely happy with
the with the dynamic that the the Monica
and I had and how well we worked
together and played together the the
various different scenes and then
watching her doing the stunts and and
being willing to go and to rehearse with
the stand crew in order so I I think
that the whole thing was really a
fantastic experience doing this series
and I've done TV work in the past as you
know in the 70s and 80s if you know but
it was not the episode episode uh or a
whole season or something like that it
was just a you know a part here and a
part there or guest starring in this
show or that show and so on
Monica your resume of working with
Hollywood Legends is pretty good so far
I gotta say yes when someone told me
yesterday I should buy a lottery ticket
because apparently I'm very lucky is it
just a note you give your agent like
Legends only please
no no
um but no I mean yeah I've been I've
been
super lucky I don't really have any
family in this industry or a lot of my
friends do very different things for a
living and so it's nice to get to not
only meet people in the industry and
have mentorship but to have that sort of
thing from
Legends is is pretty wild
the consensus with the cast
um Arnold is that they adore you and
they say that you're such a cool guy to
be around just the most generous onset
Monica can you confirm no it's all lies
this is the absolute worst
um yeah of course of course we had a
great time he shows up so prepared he's
so professional but he also has a way of
like keeping it fun and light and that
is a hard balance to strike in in a SAT
environment and he's very very good with
it
now Arnold you've got this with Netflix
also coming up you've got that
three-part docu series Arnold with
Netflix
um how do you know that it's the right
time to release a documentary like this
about your life and career
you know I don't know
and I don't make that decision
nor do I make the decision that the
documentary is being made about me in
the first place so this is Netflix's
deal I have very little to do with this
whole thing other than having to sit
there for
I don't know how many hours 40 hours of
interviews and stuff like that that I
agreed to do and uh because I want to
have my story and my side of the story
told by me
um and um you know when it comes out
Netflix makes us decisions and I think
it could easily be that the response of
this series of fubar
was so great and the response to the
trail of uban all of this that they said
you know I think we could be very
successful with football here and it
could be a huge hit and I think with
that we should just be right 14 days
later come out then with the with the
documentary with the three-part
documentary called Arnold and uh so
that's what they decided to do I don't
make those decisions is a Maverick was
just made the chief action officer of
Netflix and so I only make decisions now
when it comes to action series or action
movies that I have I say but not about
documentaries or anything like that
so you're saying if I have any action
movie ideas I gotta come to you exactly
would be a good idea yeah
well again congratulations on the series
uh thank you so much for the time
absolutely thank you
I gotta say this is this is such a cool
thing to be able to say
um
I'm working with Arnold's again like
well what is this like we did anybody
else contact you on the cast that was
like Hey so uh what's your like on set
how do I uh how do I approach him was
anybody like that uh you know I I'm
trying to remember I don't think um
you know I don't think so he's he's so
generous and accessible and he knows
what he means to people he wants to be
there for you he wants you to win more
than you do you know when it comes to
your work so
um and I think that he has a he has a
different relationship with everybody
and
um you know there was definitely a sense
that you know they they knew that we had
the history and it was you know it's
probably kind of weird that the villain
and the hero are eating lunch in the
same trailer and having schnitzels but
it's um
but we love each other man and uh and
and it's um I was really happy I really
love to see the rest of the cast have
that experience because it's one that
not everyone has you know and it's cool
to have other people that you can you
know you can um share this Mutual
experience with and to see to see their
hearts light up their eyes light up and
and um because it never we say it all
the time it never gets normal to be in
the presence of Arnold Schwarzenegger
um so I'm happy they're now on this ride
to you know this because he keeps his
people you know people his friends he
keeps him he's very loyal friend and
keeps them for years and years and years
so you know I look forward to seeing
more Arnold and Fortune feamster action
Duos
I I think it's also a very unique thing
to be able to say that you kind of have
more experience in a particular field
than one of you know actions greatest
legends in that this is his first TV
series right did you did you see him
operate in a particular way that was
different than what you had seen before
absolutely absolutely uh he was a very
studious governor on this shoot I mean
he he would spend nights he you know
we'd go we'd have dinner uh you know we
have to have a stogie whatever and he's
you know I have to study so he just he
would go him and Walter his uh his uh uh
the his acting acting uh coach that he
works with who's been with him for years
and years him you know once again his
loyalty he's has the same team and it's
the same like three four guys and and
that's his those are his guys you know
um but yeah he's sitting there
learning eight pages instead of you know
one or two one-liners Terminator zingers
you know he's learning Eight Pages of
CIA jargon and family Dynamics and and
uh and then delivering and not getting
enough knocking it out of the park you
know